we start today with President Joe
Biden's speech in Warsaw Poland this is
a speech that the president gave after
his visit to Ukraine this is a visit in
general and also in particular a speech
that has really exposed the worst of the
worst of the authoritarian right-wing in
the United States and one of the
fascinating things is we're going to
look at some clips here of this speech
that President Biden gave uh President
Biden focused in on a criticism of
autocrats and authoritarians
overtly he's talking about Vladimir
Putin but when you listen to the
criticism this would just as accurately
apply to the authoritarian autocratic
dictatorial wannabe magarite of the
United States Joe Biden was super strong
in this speech Let's Take a look at this
first section about autocracy and the
importance of opposing it anywhere that
we see it president cruises craving lust
for land and power will fail
and the Ukrainian people's love for
their country will prevail
democracies of the world will stand
guard over Freedom today tomorrow and
forever
so that's what is that's what's at stake
here freedom
that's the message I'd carry to Keith
yesterday
directly to the people of Ukraine
when president zielinski said he came to
the United States in December quote he
said this struggle
will Define the world and what our
children and grandchildren how they live
and then their children and
grandchildren
he wasn't only speaking about the
children and grandchildren of Ukraine
he was speaking about all of our
children and grandchildren yours and
mine
we're seeing again today with the people
of Poland
and the people across Europe saw for
decades
appetites of the autocrat
cannot be appeased they must be opposed
autocrats only to understand one word no
no no no
you will not take my country
no you will not take my freedom no you
will not take my future
and I'll repeat tonight what I said last
year in the same place
a dictator
better rebuilding an Empire will never
be able to ease the people's love of
Liberty
brutality will never grind down the will
of the free
and Ukraine
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
so one of Biden's strongest speeches and
of course he doesn't write these he puts
his touch on them but he's not writing
these speeches but the message as much
as it here is designed for Putin it
could go for Orban
it could go for trump it could go for
the former Brazilian president jair
bolsonaro all of these autocrats have
this wannabe dictator streak and what is
stunning is that even though the right
has claimed a monopoly on freedom and
liberty in the United States for at this
point probably two decades uh it is
increasingly the right that wants to
restrict freedoms of all sorts of Kinds
what can we teach
what can we say
what can social media companies do what
can other private Industries do what can
people do in their bedroom what pronouns
can people choose to be called by right
increasingly it's the Democratic party
of which I am not a part as many of you
know I have no particular concern with
the Democratic party but this happens to
be a Democratic president
who is actually the one talking about
freedom and liberty in a more serious
way
um Joe Biden continued and said that uh
well let's just listen he addressed the
Ukrainian conflict specifically in the
United States together with our allies
and partners are going to continue to
have Ukraine's back as it defends itself
next year
I will host every member of NATO
for our 2024 Summit in the United States
together
will celebrate the 75th anniversary of
the strongest defensive Alliance in the
history of the world NATO
and
let there be no doubt
the commitment of the United States to
our NATO alliance and Article 5 is Rock
Solid
so there can be reasonable and spirited
debate as to how large should the
American contribution to Ukraine be how
long lasting should the commitment be
and is it fair or reasonable for the
United States to be
disproportionately supporting Ukraine in
comparison to other Allied countries all
of those are reasonable conversations
but what Joe Biden distilled clearly in
this speech is something that it's
shocking people still have to be
reminded of it and I know they do
because Vladimir Putin recently said in
his address something along the lines of
the U.S started this war Ukraine started
this war wasn't Russia who started the
war Russia started the war
this is a defensive situation for
Ukraine and Joe Biden doing a good job
of pointing that out
um and then going further in terms of
what the U.S and Western allies are
seeking and what they are not seeking so
tonight
I speak once more to the people of
Russia
the United States nations of Europe do
not seek to control or destroy Russia
the West Was Not plotting to attack
Russia as Putin said today right and
millions of Russian citizens
we'll only want to live in peace with
our neighbors are not the enemy
this war is never a necessity
it's a tragedy
President Putin chose this war
every day the war continues is his
choice
he could end the war with a word
it's simple
if Russia stopped invading Ukraine it
would end the war
if you crane stop defending itself
against Russia would be the end of
Ukraine
that's why together we're making sure
Ukraine can defend itself yeah and again
it is stunning that this has to be
repeated you can still make the case
that despite it being a defensive
situation for Ukraine the US's
involvement should have limits that's a
perfectly reasonable conversation to
have I don't know of anyone on the left
who is saying that these are unlimited
blank checks for the end of time that is
not what I'm hearing anybody's saying if
somebody is saying that please let me
know but the context and the
circumstances in which this is happening
must be restated regularly because there
is a propaganda effort from Putin and
from others to pretend that the
circumstances are different let's next
talk about how this entire Ukraine visit
has broken the brains of many right
Wingers yesterday we talked a little bit
about how Joe Biden's visit to Ukraine
on President's Day can you imagine has
been used to say well he really should
have been at the border or he really
should really should have been in East
Palestine I was told very politely by
people I was mispronouncing it yesterday
this is the problem when I only read
news as opposed to watch it I don't know
that it's pronounced Palestine instead
of Palestine okay the argument that some
of these right-wingers were making was
oh it was the wrong day to go to Ukraine
instead of the Border or to Ohio uh the
brains of a lot of these folks continue
to break endlessly uh don Jr made the
argument
that it was particularly bad that Biden
went to Ukraine on President's Day
because Russia is to blame for the train
derailments I mean it's it's all making
very little sense hey we have
derailments after train derailment with
environmental disasters no one asking if
it's maybe the Russians retaliating
after the article came out about us
possibly attacking the Nordstrom 2
pipeline okay that article has been
widely debunked and it's based on almost
nothing the the article has been
ridiculed widely and has been widely
debunked we actually know with almost
total certainty what happened with the
train derailment there are hot box
detectors which are recommended to be
placed every 20 or 25 miles to determine
is something getting too hot on the
train a bearing or other things
there is video footage that suggests
that 20 miles out of East Palestine
there was already a fire on the train
there was no such detector there to
notify the train crew as a result
because it is not a requirement to have
those hot box detectors
we ended up with what we ended up with
and Don Jr is talking about Russia you
know the the trumps love to say why does
everybody talk about Russia he's talking
about Russia when it makes no sense to
be talking about Russia and it's all
because their brains are broken also
important to mention
over time train derailments per person
per mile traveled have continued to
decline in the United States they're not
actually up there are still too many
trained derailments and they are
unfortunately regular thing if you count
train and Subway and all these different
things
but derailments have actually declined
so that's Don Jr Ben Shapiro on the
other hand suggests with no evidence
that the air raid sirens in the
background of Biden's visit to Ukraine
were
um stage managed they were staged for
Biden's visit
a clip came out of Joe Biden walking
through Kiev with Vladimir zielinski and
the air raid sirens go off
uh It's Curious it's weird they don't
even break nobody even nobody even for a
second in the Press pool like looks
around like normally when the air raid
sirens go off and I've been in countries
when Airaid Sirens have gone off right I
mean like I was in Jerusalem last year
the era teens didn't actually go off in
Jerusalem but they you were checking
your phone consistently for like where
are the rocket attacks falling isn't
that the best he goes I've been in
countries where Air Raid Sirens are
going off like for example I was in
Jerusalem actually the air raid sirens
weren't going off but I was keeping a
really close eye on my phone uh
that's it's ridiculous
people tend to have a tendency when a
giant noise goes off that says you
should get through shelter people tend
to at least look in the air in this clip
nobody looks in the air there's a reason
for that as we'll explain in just a
moment here was Joe Biden with Vladimir
zielinski yesterday walking through cave
[Music]
hey well there's only a couple of
problems with that clip one again nobody
looks in the air while the air raid
sirens are going off the second is that
a CNN reporter then went on the air and
he's like oh yeah by the way um we
haven't heard nearest for like five
weeks
literally the only moment I've heard
siren the last five weeks has been when
Joe Biden walked outside with Vladimir
zielinski which sort of suggests that
what they really wanted was a photo op a
big Brave Joe Biden dark aviator glasses
dark Brandon walking around keep with
the air raid sirens going off like
Winston Churchill and the rubble of
London or something all right so there's
Ben Shapiro's incisive commentary the
air raid sirens were certainly staged
and then here's Fox news reporter
deporter reporter Peter Ducey who didn't
like the tone I guess of the Biden
speech and
um Okay let's listen President Biden
disagrees with that and we expect him to
expand on that theme later on today uh
at this speech which should start in a
few minutes and it's not the solemn set
of remarks that we were kind of told to
expect based on the existential threats
that he sees it has almost a campaign
rally feel like uh like if they were
having a campaign rally for democracy
virus wow how terrible that would be
let's rally for democracy which is in
Peril and in danger the world over
um so uh
this wasn't it wasn't a sad enough event
for Peter Ducey the atmosphere was like
too rally-like in favor of democracy
which seems by the way like a pretty
worthy cause to me so they don't even
know what sorts of criticisms to make at
this point in time because the truth is
Biden looked Strong by going to Ukraine
so they go well President's Day was the
wrong day to go or he should have been
at the derailment or he should have been
at the border or the atmosphere should
have been sadder or the air raid sirens
were staged or Russia did the derailment
or whatever the case may be for which
it's conspiracies and whining ultimately
what we are getting from the right at
this point in time their brains are
cracking like an egg and breaking uh and
I don't expect this to change at all
anytime soon meanwhile Trump's spending
time on Truth social posting about Ron
DeSantis and almost nobody's paying
attention so you can understand why
they're upset and why they're scrambling
and why they are so triggered later in
the program we will look at sort of more
these are slightly more cartoonish
reactions we're going to look at kind of
the the scarier reactions from some on
the right to the news over the last 72
hours stay with us remember we can
really use your help getting to 2
million YouTube subscribers go to
youtube.com the davidpackman show slam
that subscribe button we appreciate it
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene is really living
up to her nickname Marjorie Trader green
lately what started with the suggestion
via Twitter that the country needs a
national divorce in which we split into
two countries a country of red States
and a country of blue States has not
been unilaterally denounced by The Wider
Republican party and actually seems to
be getting some support from Fox News
propagandist Sean Hannity we knew when
we saw that Trader green was trying to
push her way into being taken more
seriously by the Republican Party once
Republicans took control of the House of
Representatives and it seems as though
to some degree it is working so let's
look at the tweets that started it all
Marjorie Taylor green tweeting quote why
the left and right should consider a
national divorce not a civil war but a
legal agreement to separate our
ideological and political disagreements
by States while maintaining our legal
union definition of irreconcilable
differences inability to agree on most
things or unimportant things tragically
I think we the left and right have
reached irreconcilable differences I'll
speak for the right and say we are
absolutely disgusted and fed up with the
left cramming and forcing their ways on
us and our children with no respect for
our religion Faith Traditional Values
and economic and government policy
beliefs so she goes on to explain more
and to make this case on Twitter that we
need a national divorce she then
appeared yesterday on the Sean Hannity
program Sean Hannity is a Fox News
propagandist and she said I don't want
to see Civil War
but that's the direction that things are
going
and here's my question you know how did
you get to this this
point I mean I look at topics for
example how do you reconcile defund the
police and no bail laws with Law and
Order how do you reconcile secure
borders and wide open borders how do you
well the way you reconcile it is
nobody's serious on the left is saying
that the police should be defunded and
I've not seen anyone argue for open
borders you reconcile it by realizing
that you're lying
reconcile energy independence with
energy dependence and new green dealism
how do you reconcile peace through
strength uh with with people that want
to gut our defense you know there I
don't see middle ground on a lot of
these issues so what is the other answer
if it's not a divorce
so look at that Hannity saying the
divorce is the natural way to go
well exactly Sean that's the problem and
where we are today and in in my life and
my world I all of my friends are regular
Americans everyone I talk to is sick and
tired and fed up of being bullied by the
left abused by the left and disrespected
by the left and our ideas our policies
our ways of life have become so far
apart that it's just coming to that
point and the last thing I ever want to
see in America is a civil war no one
wants that at least everyone I know
would never want that right but it's
going that direction and we have to do
something about it wow
wow now there are so many different
directions that we could go with this
idea
um but the most important thing to
understand which makes the entire idea
Dead on Arrival
for them is that the blue State country
if we were to divide up so to speak the
blue State country would be fine
the red State country would not be
viable
because these folks they don't like to
admit it but look at the data blue
States regularly outperform red States
in terms of GDP per capita now a lot of
people say well the blue states have
higher GDP because they have more
population well but look at it per
capita okay the blue States would end up
being quite a wealthy country the red
States as a country not so much blue
states have more diverse economies blue
States aren't as reliant on any one
industry or sector red States on average
are extraordinarily reliant on one
Industry Texas overwhelmingly is an oil
state
Kansas overwhelmingly an Agriculture
state this makes their the red State
economies significantly less Dynamic and
dramatically more vulnerable to one
industry fluctuating blue States tend to
have more educated workforces which
leads to higher paying jobs more
Innovation and larger tax revenues with
which to do things the larger tax
revenues have left blue states with
dramatically better infrastructure than
red states which makes it easier for
businesses to go to the blue States and
for goods to be transported between and
out of and Into the Blue States so
that's where the businesses are going to
continue going you look at education
dramatically better in blue States you
look at Health Care dramatically better
in blue States so when you look at all
that
that alone should make you question
could a red State country even survive
but then look at the the maybe one of
the most important things
you look at Federal subsidies red states
are disproportionately reliant on
federal subsidies States like
Mississippi Kentucky and others who
receive so much more money from the
federal government than they contribute
on the other hand you have so many blue
states that are over contributing in
order to subsidize those red States so
if you separate that and say well now
we've only got I guess some some red
state federal government
economically and financially it doesn't
make sense so you can talk about is this
possible is this legal can States
unilaterally secede or whatever you know
all these different conversations
they're asking for something that would
not be a viable country because of the
realities of blue and red States one
other by the way unconstitutional thing
that was suggested during this Marjorie
Taylor green wants if you move from a
red state to from a blue state to a red
State because the blue states are so
terrible despite all the indicators
being better
um you don't get to vote right away
which by the way is not the way the law
Works explaining why she thinks this is
a good idea green is saying that a
national divorce would Empower
individual states to form a smaller
government reduce the federal debt set
their own environmental standards and
the congresswoman has another idea as
well Banning people who move from Blue
states to Red States from voting for
five years so they don't bring their bad
politics with them I actually favor that
idea he likes it okay completely illegal
doesn't make any sense can't do it
couldn't do it would never pass
unconstitutional makes makes no sense
whatsoever so two parts to this three
parts to this Marjorie Taylor green
support something that is outrageous
number two the entire thing actually
wouldn't work blue States would be fine
red States would fail and number three
it's actually getting some support from
people as visible as Fox News propaganda
Sean Hannity very scary stuff I want to
briefly look at a statement that the
failed former president Donald Trump
made
in which he announced that he will end
crime well cool like I mean listen as I
said earlier Trump should have just
banned the virus that would have been
the simplest way to end the pandemic and
who why not it's genius right just End
crime and then you don't have to deal
with it Trump
extraordinarily swollen and very much
slurring during this wacky bizarre
statement
Joe Biden and to defund the police
Democrats have turned our once great
cities into cesspools of Bloodshed and
crime so already okay we are we're 13
seconds in but the first six seconds
were silent okay so we're seven seconds
in
Trump is already telling Endless Lies
the defund the police Democrats I still
never met them I get a few emails every
once in a while from people who go we
should defund the police
overwhelmingly what the left wants is
what I've outlined which is reform the
police retrain the police reorganize the
police
and by the way the idea of rampant crime
on average crime is down over time and a
lot of people don't want to acknowledge
this Oklahoma has a higher per capita
crime rate than New York State Oklahoma
City has a higher violent violent crime
rate per capita than New York City
but it doesn't matter okay seven seconds
it takes me a minute to tell you the
lies that have been included in that
seven second period there's never been
anything like it here's my plan to
restore Law and Order
in our cities and throughout our country
frankly first because police forces have
been gutted by democrats war on police I
will sign a record investment in hiring
retention and training for police
officers Nationwide so important this
bill will also increase vital liability
protections for officers he wants more
liability protection for officers now I
am not someone who says there should be
no special protection afforded to police
officers it is undeniable that police
officers face a certain type of risk
that people who do you know baking or
podcasting or whatever don't I
acknowledge that and I I don't think
very many people would deny that
but what we don't need are blanket
protections that make it so police don't
even consider
the consequences of their actions and so
eliminating those those minimum things
makes no sense whatsoever because the
Democrats want to take those protections
away from our police because we want
them to do their jobs and we want them
to do their jobs right you can't take
their protections away if you're going
to have them do their jobs
second to qualify for this new funding
and all other justice department grants
I will insist that local jurisdictions
return to proven Common Sense policing
measures such as stop and frisk so Trump
will require stop and frisk stop and
frisk which has been widely analyzed as
a disaster when it was used in in New
York City and in other places Trump says
not only do I recommend I will require
stop and frisk wow very simple you stop
them and you Frisk them strictly
enforcing existing gun laws against
evicted felons cracking down on the open
use of illegal drugs and cooperating
with ice to get criminal aliens off our
streets and get them out of our country
third we will go after the radical
Marxist prosecutors who are abolishing
cash bail I would be shocked to find I
mean listen might there be one
is there a judge somewhere that's a
Marxist is there a prosecutor somewhere
that is actually a Marxist
Maybe
but the idea that there are Marxist
judges and prosecutors as a matter of
common occurrence is a joke there are
like no marxists in the United States
very I mean they exist very very few
refusing to charge crimes and
surrendering our cities to Violent
criminals they have surrendered like
never before like dogs I will direct the
doj to open civil rights investigations
into radical left prosecutors officers
such as those in Chicago LA and San
Francisco to determine whether they have
illegally engaged in race-based
enforcement of the law I will also work
with Congress to give the victims of
their Marxist policies the right to sue
are you a victim of Marxism in 2023 in
the United States call now for a free
evaluation
how stupid does this sound victims of
Marxism local officials for harm and
suffering and it has been great that
they have caused if your small business
is pillaged because shoplifting goes
punished if you're brutally attacked by
a violent felon released without bail or
Bond then you will be entitled to
massive damages fourth I will order thee
did Marxism touch you inappropriately
have you been damaged by it has the
labor theory of value perverted your
children call now you may be entitled to
compensation Department of Justice or
some people call it the
Department of Injustice right now and
Homeland Security dismantle every gang
Street crew and Drug Network in America
every single one of them will be
dismantled we already know where these
turf wars and Drug dens are we know who
the People Are People I'm going to
charge them and charge the culprits with
every crime that we can find I don't
know why he's screaming I genuinely
don't going to be fair but we're going
to be tough we also need the death
penalty for drug dealers so important
and I'd add to that human traffickers
human drug dealers and human traffickers
kill them get the death penalty there
you go watch it stop and stop quickly
all right so there is Trump's plan to
End crime and uh it never really makes
any sense
uh what he says it also doesn't make
sense that his right eye is almost
completely swollen shut I've still never
been able to understand that so
I didn't know it was so simple uh
compensate the victims of Marxism and uh
you will be well on your way to ending
crime so these are the by the way
this counts as policy to right Wingers
when right-wingers see this they go look
this is this isn't culture where this is
this is policy Trump will compensate the
victims of Marxism and that's a great
policy that he is proposing off the
rails completely off the rails uh we'll
have this clip and others on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the David Pacman
show we will also have this clip and
others available in Spanish on the
Spanish YouTube channel davidpackman.com
Spanish make sure you are subscribed
make sure to let your Spanish-speaking
friends relatives and neighbors know if
they want to get progressive political
commentary but they prefer it in Spanish
the place to go is davidpackman.com
Spanish we'll take a quick break and the
program continues right after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show a
republican official has been banned from
Twitter after suggesting that Joe Biden
the President should be killed yes this
is where we are folks it's 2023 and
unfortunately this is where we are and
we've got to deal with it the news Times
reports Brookfield Republican first
Select manterra Car kicked off Twitter
after post targeting President Biden now
we actually have the post and we're
going to put it up on the screen for you
there was a video here
um of tweeted by the RNC research
account
which was a video of Kamala Harris
saying we have a lot to be thankful for
in Joe Biden and Tara Carr the elected
official responded to it by saying he
meaning Joe Biden he's aiding and
abetting the enemy Ready Aim Fire one
shot one kill that simple there is not a
lot of nuance there there is not a lot
of nuance there that is a call to shoot
dead the president of the United States
from a republican official as I
mentioned she's been kicked off Twitter
oh Twitter has a liberal bias oh
something just fell off my microphone
that was weird Twitter has a liberal
bias Twitter has because they they said
oh now all of a sudden you get kicked
off for calling for the assassination of
the president what won't they allow next
these folks are genuinely dangerous not
because tarakar herself is likely to go
and kill Joe Biden but because an
environment in which it is even remotely
acceptable to say these things if
particularly forget as an average person
but as an as a republican official to
say something like this anything short
of complete denouncement disavow and if
it's on a social media platform Banning
the person
um could be seen as some kind of an
endorsement or approval of it a
republican Town committee chair George
Blass defended the post saying that Carr
was saying shoot the balloon shoot the
balloon not Joe Biden and that it was
taken out of context
um
it genuinely doesn't appear at all that
that is what
um she is arguing for
so there it is another insane action by
these dangerous right Wingers all right
this is just funny okay we're gonna have
fun now this is what fun looks like when
the country has been partially taken
over by lunatics uh Marjorie Taylor
green had another funny gaffe where she
has come out against hiring based on
ethnicity now you might be saying well
David what do you mean what's ethnicity
she clearly means ethnicity but as usual
has no idea what she's talking about but
she's against it that's for sure you
know private businesses want to hire
based on characteristics and someone's
ability to do the job well no the
Democrats in the last one want
businesses to have to hire based on skin
color
um ethnicity or even what gender they
identify I would go further it's not
just that the woke left wants ethnicity
based hiring the left wants ethnine
semanticity based hiring and that's the
first question I ask on my job
applications when we look to hire people
what is your ethanament authenticity and
of course Marjorie Taylor green very
well known for these sorts of gaffes at
one point she referred to a petri dish
as a peach tree dish you have to accept
the fact that the government totally
wants to provide surveillance on every
part of your life
when you're eating they want to know if
you're eating a cheeseburger which is
very bad because Bill Gates wants you to
eat his fake meat that goes in a peach
tree dish pizza you'll probably get a
little zap inside your body and that say
no no so there's Peach Tree dish also of
course infamously the gazpacho police
not only do we have the DC jail which is
the DC Gulag but now we have Nancy
Pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of Congress spying on the
legislative work that we do when she
said this I knew she was a real bisque
if you know what I mean and then this
one is not Marjorie Taylor green but I
just it's too good not to include
um Lauren bobert very famously coming
out against wonton killings they made
life hell on Earth with their Envy
wonton killing I don't know what a
wonton killing is
I'm gonna have to look that one up yeah
it's like attempted murder By broad
noodle is what I've read it uh it
actually works out too so anyway these
people are clueless that are clueless
about really important things but they
also just regularly make up words and
they're so confident that's maybe the
the saddest part of the entire thing
ladies and gentlemen
I have a momentous bit of news for all
of you I know I hope everybody is
sitting down because there is something
that happened last night on the Tucker
Carlson program that is absolutely
rocked the Republican primary and is
completely changing the Dynamics Vivek
ramaswamy has announced that he is
entering the Republican primary
I know I know I'm giving everybody time
to react to this uh no one cares and
it's really really even Tucker Carlson
kind of seems not to care it's it's kind
of sad to be honest Vivek ramaswamy is
it
this is so stupid he's an anti-woke
entrepreneur and he founded last year
something called strive Asset Management
it's an asset management firm which on
its websites on its website says it
seeks to restore the voices of everyday
citizens
oh okay that sounds pretty pretty cool
so anyway here he is and it's just like
a deflated balloon
take a look at this on you know just a
cable hose but this is a perfect
illustration of where identity politics
wind up right when you stray from
Universal principles that bind us all
under the same rules exactly I mean we
are in the middle of this national
identity crisis Tucker where we have
celebrated our diversity and our
differences for so long yeah that we
forgot all of the ways we're really just
the same as Americans Bound by a common
set of ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago whoa and that's
what I'm proud to say tonight that I'm
running for United States President wow
those ideals in this country those basic
rules of the road meritocracy the idea
that you get ahead in this country not
on the color of your skin but in the
content of your character right the idea
that you are allowed to speak freely yes
to be wrong sometimes as long as your
neighbor gets the same courtesy in
return the idea that the people who we
elect to run the government by the way
are the people who actually run the
government basic rules of the road these
are the things that bind us together you
and I have different shades of melon and
you know what I'd say so what you know I
could have sworn that he said different
shades of shades of melon
like you know uh
Tucker's more of a honeydew guy whereas
Vivek is really preferential to
cantaloupe but I I think what he's
saying is different shades of melanin
right like different skin color that's
not beautiful that is not our strength
our diversity is meaningless if there's
nothing greater that binds us together
across that diversity yeah and the
reason that I'm running for president is
to revive those ideals and I believe
deep in my bones they still exist that
most Americans still believe in them but
we need to ReDiscover that and the only
way we can do it is by start to talking
openly start talking openly again so I'm
not going to ask you yeah
um really a momentous thing and then on
Twitter Vivek ramaswamy announced he
will end affirmative action tweeting
quote as U.S president as U.S president
I will end federally mandated
affirmative action full stop I will
repeal Lyndon Johnson's Executive Order
11246 which mandates race-based quotas
every Republican since Johnson had the
opportunity to do it I'll do it on day
one without apology well he won't do it
and it won't be day one there will be no
day one
um and there is just something funny
about you know in particular like when
somebody like this announces
do you think they know that this is a
joke
or do they actually sit somewhere and go
you never know I might be able to pull
this thing out I'm just not sure but a
very very big get as you can see for
Tucker Carlson getting this announcement
on his program and this certainly we
will have to spend some serious time
figuring out how this announcement from
ramaswamy
is going to completely upend the
Dynamics of the Republican primary so
stay with us for more on that maybe
someday if it becomes a real thing we're
going to take a quick break and much
more to discuss I'm very much glad
you're with us today
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
will Donald Trump's brain appears to
have been broken by Ron DeSantis Trump
is now posting daily to truth Central
about it truth Central yeah truth truth
social now I'm calling it the wrong
thing uh truth truth social yes not
truth Central
um you know a few days ago Donald Trump
said he never thinks about Ron DeSantis
and that made me think that all Trump is
thinking about is Ron DeSantis and Trump
is now just posting daily about DeSantis
Trump is obsessed with a guy who hasn't
actually announced that he's running
against Trump yet let's take a look at a
couple of these posts every day it is
something here is one from a couple of
days ago Donald Trump posting quote so
interesting to watch Fox News cover the
small and unenthusiastic 139 person
crowd in Staten Island for DeSantis but
stay as far away as possible from
coverage of the thousands of people many
unable to get in at the the club 47
event in West Palm Beach Florida I call
Fox News the Rhino Network and their
down big ratings accurately reflect the
name
if fake news CNN was smart which they're
not they'd go conservative and all Trump
all the time like in 2016 and become a
capital R ratings capital J Juggernaut
there are like 10 fascinating things
about this post and you have to
understand the context and kind of be
aware of the back story on a lot of
these things first and and foremost
Trump's continued obsession with crowds
DeSantis had 139 people I had thousands
Fox news is talking about that crowd
they're not talking about my crowd
that's bad secondly anything short of
complete brown-nosing and sucking up up
to Trump immediately gets you branded a
rhino if you're a republican who is
anything other than completely an
unflinchingly and blindly loyal to Trump
you're a rhino if you are a network and
you cover what a different Republican
did instead of what Trump did you are a
rhino and then lastly again Trump's idea
he's mentioned this a number of times
now that CNN could really do something
stunning if they were to become
conservative like Fox that everybody
would flock to CNN even after Trump has
been bashing CNN for the greater part of
a decade at this point in time
um and he's probably right I mean the
truth is if CNN became conservative and
Trump said CNN is the place to go I'm
sure that its followers who have spent
years talking about how CNN is some kind
of marxist satanic influence on American
society I'm sure they would just go over
there again remember Trump told us he's
not thinking about Ron DeSantis but he's
posting about Ron DeSantis every single
day
his next post quote Florida was doing
great long before Ron de Sanctus got
there
uh people are fleeing by the way
the Sanctus is really funny I I know
that it went to first it was
dissanctimonious but I don't know if to
say this
is a uh is a typo of Trump's nickname
for DeSantis or it's the next Evolution
but there is something funny about that
okay people are fleeing from New York to
Florida and other places because of high
taxes and out of control crime not
because of Governor thank you president
Trump to sanctimonious Rick Scott did
great and even Charlie Crist had very
good numbers sunshine and ocean very
alluring so I think the point Trump is
trying to make here is Florida is great
but it has nothing to do with desanctus
it's great because of the sunshine and
the ocean and the
um you know low no state income tax and
all this stuff I speaking of the taxes
and this is a tangent but I believe it's
an appropriate one if you will allow it
um when I talked last week about
oh am I moving to Florida and I said
well I'm not moving to Florida but it is
seeming pretty appealing to spend like
January and February in Florida and
avoid some of the Northeast you know
gray dark Winters or whatever some
people wrote in saying David I know
you're really talking about that because
you want to pay no state income tax now
the truth is if you live for two months
in Florida you know these northern
states New York Connecticut
Massachusetts they don't let you stop
paying income tax so I believe that you
have to spend like more at least more
than half the year in order to be able
to say I live in Florida but then other
people wrote to me and said David if
you're actually thinking about the
Florida thing because you want to avoid
state income tax they get you in other
ways because property taxes are very
high and other taxes are and all these
different that I don't even know if
that's true it's totally plausible to me
that maybe it's not actually cheaper tax
wise to live in Florida because you save
on state income but you pay I don't even
know I've not looked into it but it
wouldn't shock me if that were true as
far as the Sanctus
um Ron DeSantis isn't even running and
Trump is posting daily about him just
imagine what the next year is going to
be like if DeSantis does run and it
appears as though he is gearing up for
that I want to talk a little bit about
book Banning one of the comments that
I'm seeing pretty regularly on the
shorts YouTube shorts that I post about
Republican book Banning efforts is
people commenting and saying Banning
these books is good because they're only
Banning pornographic books and books
that aren't age appropriate let me show
you some of the comments that I've been
receiving
uh the I won't even name the P these are
just YouTube people uh with long strings
as their usernames but here are some of
the comments how is Banning a porno book
on a middle school library fascism isn't
it at worst censorship based on age and
at best parenting and protecting
children from losing their innocence
sooner than necessary it's not fascism
if it's inappropriate content for kids
schlock of God says no Banning books
that are not appropriate for kids is
morally correct JP music says there's a
huge difference between limiting what
book schools can have available for kids
and removing books from public libraries
or not allowing the sale of certain
books JD says have you looked at the
content of the books many are
pornographic in nature Dr Ox says it
depends on what books are being banned
um Planet positivity says false when it
applies to children extremists on the
far left and right want their propaganda
talk to kids and both are age
inappropriate Jan says it's critical
that parents be able to make these
decisions I don't want the government
deciding what my kid can and can't read
but Billy beans said restrictions
imposed by parents are equally bad as
restrictions imposed by governments if
not worse Jay says Banning books is not
the same as removing non-age appropriate
books from elementary school libraries
so I decided to look at some of the
books that are being banned and you can
easily find these these lists penn.org
has a list and here's some of the books
that are regularly banned one is called
genderqueer a memoir
and it's about a person who uses
pronouns like air
and explains why to their family this
one's been banned more than 40 times all
boys aren't Blue by George Johnson which
is a series of essays from
um an LGBT activist that explores his
childhood and Adolescence out of
darkness by Ashley hope Perez a
dangerous forbidden romance rocks a
Texas oil town in 1937 when segregation
was a matter of life and death The
Bluest Eye by Toni Morrison because it
obsesses it examines our obsession with
beauty and Conformity and you can go
through these and you can get a bigger
list and this is going to be sort of
hard to see because of the zoom but you
see that there are all these different
books that have been banned some have
been banned by administrators some have
been challenged by parents you see all
these different examples and I have to
tell tell you I spent time randomly
picking these books and I went to Amazon
and I did the look inside and I read you
know a number of pages that are
available the vast majority of these
books are neither pornographic nor
extreme however many of them do have
story lines that it seems many right
Wingers don't like sometimes there are
gay characters
that's it so they want the book banned
sometimes there are descriptions of
sexual encounters and we could have a
conversation is that appropriate for
seven-year-olds well maybe not but is it
appropriate for high school juniors yeah
it's fine in some of them there are
descriptions of non-binary people or
whatever the case may be the
overwhelming majority of these books are
not pornographic and
it is very clear that a lot of the
people saying it's good to ban these
books have absolutely no idea what is in
the books I also want to say another
thing a lot of these books don't seem
that great to me and what I mean by this
I'm not saying
a lot of this stuff is just personal
preference at the end of the day right
like what kind of stuff do you enjoy
reading a lot of these books as I look
at them aren't particularly titillating
but they also don't seem particularly
interesting to me and it seems to me
that making a big deal for any reason
out of these books just doesn't really
make sense if this is a book that a
teacher wants to have in a curriculum it
just seems very strange to get all
shaken up about it and what I was
reminded of of course is that the right
Wingers that want a lot of these books
banned are really the snowflakes they
love to say oh the left is so sensitive
the left can't handle anything and all
these different things I mean listen uh
gay relationships exist
slavery existed brutality existed uh
non-binary people exist and just saying
that the inclusion of that those as
topics is quote inappropriate for quote
kids particularly when a lot of them
don't distinguish between a first grader
and a High School junior senior they
seem to be exposing themselves as the
snowflakes that can't handle any
anything and you know I don't want to
like go too far down this path but if
you look at historical efforts to ban
you know so-called degenerate art as
Nazis wanted to do if you look at all
other efforts that we've seen over time
from authoritarian leaning movements and
leaders to control media and books and
Publications it's really ugly stuff and
quite frankly it mostly seems to
backfire so take a look at the books
that they actually want to ban go on
Amazon click on look inside look read a
little bit and you will very quickly see
that this is not actually about banning
porn
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P and this caller has a
question about the impact that the train
derailment may have on the 2024 election
hey David so uh the situation is passing
Ohio
what do you think the political
ramifications will be for 2024 does this
make it harder for Democrats to win Ohio
because we are in power right now and
whatever happens
will get blamed on on Democrats or the
lack of things that are going on now do
you think that it'll have political
ramifications for 2024 thanks bye you
know I really don't I really don't now
there's the truth and there's what you
can spin the truth is that I don't know
why Democrats would be blamed for the
train derailment given that what
happened is that as far as we know right
now
the rail company
did not install HotBox detectors as
close together as they are recommended
and as a result they missed that the
train fire appeared to have started 20
miles out of East Palestine that is
nothing directly to do with Democrats
specifically It generally has to do with
under regulation the governor of Ohio is
a republican Ohio is basically run by
Republicans but it also isn't clear that
it's necessarily an Ohio thing but the
the truth of the matter is it would be
really weird to blame certainly Biden if
he's the Democratic candidate in 2024
for the train derailment train
derailments are sadly quite common
fortunately they've also declined in
frequency over time now Ohio hasn't gone
for Democrats since uh 2012 and 2008 in
2016 Trump won Ohio and won the
presidency in 2020 Trump won Ohio but
lost the presidency
I don't believe that the Ohio 2024
results are going to hinge on the train
derailment in particular
not only because it doesn't make sense
that they would but in particular
because voters have a relatively short
memory and uh I just don't think it's
going to be something Ohio voters are
going to decide on uh but if you
disagree with me let me know in the
comments we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today we're going to talk about
Putin bailing on the new start treaty we
are going to talk about critics
rejecting changes to Roald Dahl's books
as censorship and I will tell you my
position on that and we will talk a
little bit about project Veritas founder
James O'Keefe out at his organization
partially because of multiple harassment
claims as I understand it all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money sure everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad yeah help us make a little money on
the bonus show we call it funding
Independent Media you can sign up at
joinpakman.com this gets you instant
access to the bonus show it funds all
all of the work we do and you get The
Daily Show without commercials hours
before everybody else you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the discount
code 24
starts now and boy has it ever I look
forward to seeing you on today's bonus
check